Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen lieben Morgen Tim.
Schon alles gesagt zum zweiunddreißig C drei oder fällt dir noch irgendwas ein?
Wir könnten noch so über die äh EU Datenschutzreform sprechen, die waren nicht im Programm.
Logbuch äh Netzpolitik hundertsiebenundsechzig in schneller Folge. Nachdem wir uns äh letztes Mal so ausführlich über den zweiunddreißig C3 ausgekäst haben.
Schieben wir gleich nochmal was hinterher.
Weil sich das so ergeben hat, weil wir irgendwie nicht genug kriegen können. Den Hals nicht vollkriegen können. Also machen wir ein kleines Spezial ähm sozusagen als Nachtrag über, wie schon erwähnt, ein Thema, was auf dem Kongress äh gar nicht so die Rolle gespielt hat.
Nämlich die EU-Datenschutzverordnung.
Ja und ähm da können wir eigentlich auch gleich voranschreiten. Wir haben nämlich äh heute einen Gast und zwar Professor Doktor Nikolaus Forgo. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag, hallo.
Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Frau Go spricht man das aus, ja? Mit so einem schmissigen Ohr am Ende.
Aussprechen. Ist ein ungarischer Name, ähm man also bedeutet, dass Axa auf dem O bedeutet, dass es ungefähr gleich lang wie das erste O ausgesprochen wird, also man kann oder vor sagen, das ist schon gut so.
Okay, wieder was gelernt. Ja, sie sind äh Professor äh für Rechtsinformatik und IT-Recht. Äh an der Leibniz-Universität in Hannover.
Ähm seit wann?
Seit zweitausendzwo.
Also schon eine ganze Weile.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Rechtsinformatik und IT Recht.
Darüber können wir jetzt den Rest der Sendung diskutieren, ja. Also
gesagt, Rechtsinformatik ist der ältere Begriff, das geht zurück bis in die siebziger Jahre letztlich das zwanzigsten Jahrhunderts, weswegen sich Professoren und Institute, die eine lange Tradition haben
häufig.
Institute oder Professoren für Rechtsinformatik nennen und dann mit den Achtzigern, Neunzigern und Nullerjahren äh haben viele dieser Rechtsinformatiker hauptsächlich juristische Themen der Informatik behandelt und nicht mehr wie vorher auch Informatik des Rechts, ne.
Also das ist ja ganz interessant an dem Begriff Rechtsinformatiker würde man ja eigentlich erwarten, dass das eine Disziplin der Informatik ist, wie bei der Medizin Informatik oder der Wirtschaftsinformatik, ne. Und in Wirklichkeit sind aber sehr viele Juristen, die in dem Feld umlaufen,
Juristen, die sich mit Informatik beschäftigen, also Informatikrechten. Und äh meine Professur hat halt irgendwie beides drinnen. Aus diesem Grund.
Womit beschäftigt man sich da so im Wesentlichen?
Also ich persönlich hauptsächlich mit Datenschutz und Datensicherheitsrecht, ähm aber auch mit äh Rechtsinformationsanwendungen äh Information Problemen, solchen Dingen.
Deswegen auch Rechtsinformatiken und das ist dann auch durchaus mehr Informatik getrieben als nur einfach Jura.
Also insofern ist dann die äh EU-Datenschutzverordnung, die jetzt verabschiedet wurde oder verabschiedet werden wird, ich weiß gar nicht, ist der letzte Schritt jetzt eigentlich schon gemacht, äh das steht auf jeden Fall so in ihrem Fokus auch.
Sie haben das auch äh begleitet über die gesamte Zeit.
Naja, als äh äh Interessierter Außenseiter würde ich sagen, nicht? Also das ist äh fachlich halt in dem Feld, in dem ich ähm unmittelbar arbeite, aber ich war nicht oder bin nicht unmittelbar in den Gesetzgebungsprozess an irgendeiner Stelle eingebunden gewesen.
Hm. Aber sie haben das quasi so von Anfang an verfolgt auf den äh auf den ersten Metern. Was was war denn so da ihre erste Erwartungshaltung?
Na ja, ähm.
Schwierig, sich daran zu erinnern. Ich würde sagen, die ersten Erwartungshaltung war ähm endlich passiert mal irgendwas, denn die äh die europarechtlichen Grundlagen, von denen wir reden, stammen aus den
Achtzigern und neunziger, also konzeptionell aus den achtziger Jahren, rechtlich aus den neunziger Jahren, also aus Zeiten, wo irgendwie das Internet noch nicht wirklich erfunden war oder jedenfalls nicht,
wirksam war
und das erste Gefühl war, OK, jetzt passiert endlich was und die Kommission hat ja damals zweitausendzwölf mit sehr, sehr großen Pathos angekündigt, dass man sich jetzt internetfit oder moderne Zeiten fit machen würde,
und äh diese dieses erste Gefühl, aha, jetzt passiert was und vielleicht passiert auch wirklich, was ich brauche, machen das, hat sich dann schon anlässlich des Kommissionsentwurfs äh relativ schnell relativiert, weil schon der Kommissionsentwurf eigentlich
in sehr sehr vielen Bereichen nicht mehr war als eine Fortschreit. Aber immerhin, aber nicht mehr war, als eine Fortschreibung des Staates Coren. Und das hat sich ähm,
dann am Ende, finde ich, auch ähm so herausgestellt, dass das, was wir jetzt haben, nach vier Jahren Diskussionen in weiten Bereichen eine Fortschreibung dessen ist, was wir vorher auch schon hatten und das kann man jetzt natürlich als Erfolg verkaufen, weil es immerhin nicht sehr viel schlechter geworden ist.
Man kann's aber auch als Misserfolg verkaufen, äh weil halt viele Dinge, die äh sozusagen uns alle ständig beschäftigen,
weiterhin unklar oder komisch oder gar nicht geregelt sind.
Äh Fortschreibung, welches Status quo ist, ist das jetzt so die spezifisch deutsche äh Sicht oder.
Na ja, das kann man.
Gemeinsame Nenner.
Kann man gar nicht so sehr äh an vielen Punkten gar nicht so deutlich unterscheiden, denn also europarechtlich ist das Datos quo eine Richtlinie aus dem Jahr neunzehnfünfundneunzig und viel von dem, was in dieser Richtlinie steht.
Ähm geht auf auch damals schon auf Gedanken zurück, die auch unter wesentlich in Deutschland in den achtziger Jahren, also rund um das Volkstelungsurteil und nach dem Volksteilungsurteil entwickelt wurden. Also zum Beispiel schon die Unterscheidung zwischen.
Personenbezogenen und nicht personenbezogenen Daten und was das jeweils ist.
Also hat sich gar nicht so viel geändert.
Ja, also in dem konkreten Fall, was jetzt eigentlich personenbezogene Daten sind, hat sich so gut wie gar nichts geändert, weil die Definition, so wie sie jetzt im in der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung stehen wird, äh praktisch wortgleich die ist, die wir schon in der Richtlinie haben.
Und das ist äh deswegen recht unglücklich, finde ich, weil ähm wir beim Datenschutzrecht im Rechtsgebiet vor uns haben
schon die allererste Frage, nämlich worauf ist es überhaupt anwendbar? Strittig ist.
Weil man eben diesen Personenbezug so schwer festmachen kann. Also bei vielen, vielen Daten, das beginnt bei verschlüsselten Daten und endet bei
IP-Adressen und dazwischen gibt's auch noch 'ne Menge spannender Fragen, zum Beispiel aggregierte Daten oder Geodaten bei Google Streetview und so weiter und ich könnte jetzt noch viele andere Beispiele nennen, also bei vielen dieser.
Äh Probleme ist schon mal unklar, ob wir überhaupt über personenbezogene Daten reden und ob daher äh datenschutzrechtliche Regelungen anwendbar sind oder nicht. Denn wenn wir nicht über personenbezogene Daten reden, dann ist das gesamte regulatorische Regime,
früher schon und auch weiterhin nicht anwendbar.
Was bedeutet das denn für so eine also könnte man denn diesen Begriff trennscharf formulieren? Also gäbe es da Vorschläge.
Also ehrlich gesagt äh weiß ich das auch nicht, äh wenn ich ihn hätte, den Vorschlag, dann wäre ich,
berühmt, ähm aber es gäbe vielleicht Anlass, darüber nachzudenken, ob dieser Grunddifferenzierung überhaupt Sinn macht, ne. Also sie hat sicher Sinn gemacht, irgendwann in den achtziger Jahren.
Es halt einige wenige Großrechner gab und wo relativ klar war, dass wir in so einem Großrechner irgendwo ein Datenschutz über Herrn Müller oder Frau Meier drin ist, dass der schützenswert ist, nämlich Herr Müller oder Frau Meier
je mehr an Daten, je mehr an Vernetzung, je mehr an Kommunikation äh desto schwieriger wird's diese diese Differenzierung aufrecht zu erhalten
und das gilt nicht nur für den Personenbezug, sondern das gilt auch noch für eine zweite Unterscheidung, die auch schon seit neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig vorhanden ist,
nämlich die zwischen sensiblen und nicht sensiblen Daten. Ja die Richtlinie unterscheidet ja innerhalb der personenbezogenen Daten dann nochmal, weil sie sagt, bestimmte Daten sind so heikel.
Man da noch strenger sein muss als bei allen anderen. Dazu gehört also zum Beispiel Gesundheit oder sexuelle Orientierung oder politische Überzeugung oder Gewerkschaftszugehörigkeit.
Oder,
noch einige andere Ausnahmen und auch diese Differenzierung wird zunehmend schwieriger. Nicht, denn je mehr Kommunikation, desto wahrscheinlicher ist, dass irgendwo auch ein sensibles Datum auftaucht.
Desto wahrscheinlicher ist also, dass wir
in Wirklichkeit die ganze Zeit nur noch von personenbezogenen und nur noch von sensiblen Daten ausgehen müssen. Und dann kann man sich die Differenzierungen davor eigentlich weitgehend sparen und äh
ähm kann dann vielleicht überlegen, ob man nicht diese Kategorie Personenbezug nicht personenbezogen, sensibel, nicht sensibel.
Insgesamt anders fassen kann, also zum Beispiel stärker risikoorientiert fassen muss, also mehr darüber reden muss äh
weniger darüber reden muss, ob personenbezug vorliegt und ob ein sensibles Datum vorliegt. Und mehr darüber reden muss, worin eigentlich die konkreten Risiken liegen in der Datenverarbeitung. Das ist ein Ansatz
allerdings jetzt auch in der Datenschutzgrundverordnung so nicht enthalten ist und ob es ein kluger Ansatz ist, weiß ich gar nicht so genau, aber es ist zumindest etwas, worüber man nachdenken kann, glaube ich.
Hm
Jetzt wurde ja über über lange Zeit.
Viel nachgedacht. Ähm darüber, wo, äh, das, worüber nachgedacht wurde, haben wir aber allenfalls immer durch irgendwelche Leaks erfahren.
Sie haben da auch in ihrem Artikel auf Heise einiges drüber geschrieben. Wie würden sie sich denn so einen Prozess eigentlich vorstellen?
Also ich würd Ihnen schon mal bei allem Respekt
widersprechen wollen dahingehend, dass da viel nachgedacht wurde. Denn es wurde, glaube ich, gar nicht so viel nachgedacht, sondern es wurde vor allem lobbyiert. Ähm und das wurde ganz entschieden und ganz intensiv und ganz viel,
aber Lobbyismus ist selten das Ergebnis eines Nachdenkprozesses und schon gar nicht das Ergebnis eines.
Anführungszeichen Objektiven nach den Prozesse, was immer das ist. Also wir haben eine Situation, wo wir jahrelang äh wirklich eine extreme Lobbyarbeit hinter uns haben, die überwiegend ähm nur eingeschränkt transparent ist,
im Parlament ist das noch ziemlich transparent. Äh im Rat ist es sehr, sehr schwierig nachzuvollziehen, äh was da eigentlich hinter den Kulissen tatsächlich geschieht.
Und insgesamt also kommt am Ende halt etwas raus.
Äh viel lobbyiert wurde, nicht alles davon transparent ist und relativ wenig nachgedacht wurde, weil nämlich die Leute, die professionell.
Das Nachdenken betreiben, also zum Beispiel Hochschulen oder Hochschullehrer
nicht nachkommen, äh ob der schier Menge an Änderungsanträgen, ob der Schirmmenge an sich ständig ändernden Dokumenten und ob der Schwierigkeiten alle diese Dokumente ständig irgendwie tagesaktuell auch noch äh bei der Hand zu haben. Also Leute, die fürs Nachdenken bezahlt werden.
Zum Beispiel ich äh werden äh in diesem Prozess
tendenziell immer sehr spät ähm erst äh in die Lage versetzt, äh irgendwie halt eine Meinung zu entwickeln.
Ein Protest, der mir besser gefiel, wäre daher einer, wo man diese Transparenz und das Nachdenken stärker ins Vorfeld drücken könnte, also insbesondere ähm auch die äh die Ergebnisse, die beim informellen,
ähm erforderlich sind oder stark gefunden wurden, wie auch im Vorfeld
transparent gemacht werden und besser diskutiert werden. Das ist übrigens auch eine Anforderung der Forderung an Medien, nicht? Also es schreibt ja kaum jemand gerne über irgendeinen Zwischenschritt im Trilogverfahren
und weil das angeblich niemanden interessiert und äh wenn niemand drüber schreibt, dann ist es erst recht sehr schwierig, diese Informationen zu erlangen.
Also kurz gesagt, äh mehr nachdenken bedeutet, mehr objektives Nachdenken, mehr objektives Nachdenken verlangt, mehr an
Transparenz und mehr an einfach erreichbarer Information. Also meine primäre Quelle in den Tagen unmittelbar,
Nach dem äh Bekanntwerden des Kompromisses waren irgendwelche äh League-Webseiten ähm wie insbesondere Statewatch, die da wirklich äh sehr gut arbeiten. Aber das ist ja irgendwie nicht wirklich ein.
Aus aus rechtsstaatlicher Perspektive jetzt betrachtet nicht wirklich ein wünschenswerter Zustand, dass man sich über irgendwelche Leak Seiten ähm zusammenreimen muss, was wahrscheinlich beschlossen worden sein wird.
Genau das ist ja der Punkt. Was wurde denn jetzt beschlossen? Also das der letzte.
Diese letzte Einigung, von der wir jetzt überhaupt sprechen, ist ja keine,
offizielle, oder? Das ist einfach nur erstmal der Abschluss des Trilogs. Das ist jetzt noch kein Dokument, das in seiner Form jetzt schon rechtlich bindend wäre, oder?
Richtig, richtig. Also rechtlich ist es so, dass das, was da jetzt äh geleakt wurde, im Grunde genommen, ein weiteres Dokument ist neben vielen anderen, also keine eigene rechtliche äh Bedeutung hat
politisch ist es so,
dass wenn die Organe der Europäischen Union einen solchen Kompromisstext äh finden und dann publizieren äh nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass davon jetzt noch irgendwelche
erheblichen Abweichungen äh auftreten werden.
Also sprich politisch ist das, was wir auf dem Tisch haben mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit, das, was wir am Ende auch rechtlich haben werden.
Es ist ja am Ende auch eine Frage der Umsetzung. Die Richtlinie gibt ja letzten Endes nur
den Rahmen vor für äh konkrete nationale Regelungen. Inwiefern kann denn jetzt davon ausgegangen werden, dass auf Basis dieser Richtlinie,
dieses eigentliche Ziel, was ja hier äh auch allseits bejubelt wurde, einer Vereinheitlichung der Datenschutzstandards in den einzelnen Ländern auch.
Dann nach sich zieht.
Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage, weil sie auch schon ein Grundkommunikationsproblem des ganzen Prozesses deutlich macht. Denn das, was jetzt beschlossen wurde, ist eben gerade keine Richtlinie,
sondern es ist eine Verordnung
Verordnung, anders als eine Richtlinie, ist unmittelbar geltend das Recht in den Mitgliedsstaaten und das war ja auch das große politische Versprechen der Kommission vor vier Jahren, nicht wir brauchen ein Recht für einen Kontinent und das machen wir über eine Verordnung
also der der große Unterschied zu bisher ist
Es gibt hoffentlich irgendwann dann diesen einen Text und der ist unmittelbar anwendbar in Kroatien genauso wie in Griechenland und in Deutschland genauso wie in England. Wenn England in der EU bleibt. Ähm.
In Wirklichkeit ist es aber so,
an vielen, vielen Stellen der politische Kompromiss der notwendig war, um diesen einheitlichen Text herzustellen,
so aussieht, dass es sogenannte nationale Öffnungsklauseln in diesem Verordnungstext gibt. Dass also in der Verordnung zwar drinnen steht, wir schaffen ein einheitliches Recht und das sieht so und so aus.
Aber gleichzeitig auch drinnen steht, Mitgliedsstaaten können davon, wenn sie das möchten, abweisen in einer bestimmten Weise. Und das führt dazu, dass wir zwar auf der einen Seite sowas haben wie eine.
Wie ein politisches Versprechen eines einheitlichen Datenschutzrechts in Europa.
Und auf der anderen Seite aber eine politische und rechtliche Realität finden werden, die an vielen, vielen Stellen äh weiterhin nationale Sonderwege möglich machen wird.
Und das gilt auch und gerade dann auch noch für die äh für die äh Praxis, also sprich nicht nur für die Rechtsanwendungspraxis,
weil es natürlich nicht nur dann im geschriebenen Recht Unterschiede geben wird,
sondern auch noch in den, in der, in der Auslegung dieses Rechtes, insbesondere auch durch die Datenschutzbehörden. Da gibt's zwar mehr an Versuchen
zu koordinieren als bisher. Das ist auch erfreulich, prinzipiell. Aber ich bin nicht sehr optimistisch, dass diese äh Koordinationsversuche äh wahnsinnig erfolgreich sein werden,
Wenn man sich das durchaus sehr unterschiedliche Verständnis,
von Datenschutzbehörden schon auf nationaler Ebene ansieht und erst recht, wenn man das dann europaweit betrachtet, nicht das ist ja schon innerdeutsch, nicht so, dass sie dieselbe Antwort kriegen, was eigentlich die Aufgabe einer Datenschutzbehörde wäre
wenn sie in Kiel fragen oder wenn sie in München fragen und das gilt, das gilt erst recht, wenn sie jetzt auf der einen Seite in Dublin fragen und auf der anderen Seite in Berlin.
Können sie das mal so ein bisschen konkretisieren, was sie da so an, an, an Unterschieden in der Auslegung äh erwarten? Also gibt's da vielleicht irgend so ein Beispiel, wo sich das so konkret ähm abzeichnet?
Also ich vermute zum Beispiel, dass es ganz erhebliche Unterschiede weiterhin geben wird in der Zulässigkeit der Verarbeitung von personenbezogenen Daten für wissenschaftliche Zwecke, unabhängig von einer Einwilligung des Betroffenen.
Also weniger kompliziert formuliert. Sie gehen irgendwie zum Arzt, äh da werden irgendwelche Gesundheitsbezogenen Daten erhoben. Und dann hat irgendjemand die Idee, ähm diese Daten auch noch für irgendein wissenschaftliches Forschungsprojekt zu verarbeiten.
Vielleicht hat er dann auch noch die Idee diese Daten mit irgendwelchen Forschern in anderen europäischen Mitgliedstaaten zu äh teilen und äh zu übermitteln.
Und an dieser Stelle kommen dann ein paar ganz spannende Fragen, nämlich wie ist das mit informierten Einwilligungen, wie ist das mit der Sekundärnutzung ohne informierter Einwilligung, wie ist das mit der Zulässigkeit der Übermittlung in einen Drittstaat oder auch innerhalb Europas und so weiter und auf jede dieser Fragen wird, würde ich vermuten,
jede europäische Datenschutzbehörde eine andere Sichtweise haben.
Was gibt's da konkret zum Beispiel für Pole? Also wenn man jetzt mal das das Beispiel mal herausgreift, würden die da so zwei Länder fallen, die so an den äh entgegengesetzten Enden äh liegen.
Je je äh je weiter im Norden äh in Europa, desto
weniger äh relevant sind, äh informationelle Selbstbestimmungsinteressen des Betroffenen, also nordische Staaten wie Dänemark, Schweden, haben da eine andere Tradition als zum Beispiel Deutschland. Und je weiter westlich,
Also insbesondere Irland und England, desto.
Weniger regulierungsfreundlich ist der Anspruch und desto mehr ist das letztlich marktorientiert und äh nicht äh nicht öffentlich-rechtlich detaminiert, wie das in Deutschland der Fall wäre. Ja, also Unterschiede aus deutscher Perspektive,
sowohl nach Norden wie auch nach Westen, die relativ schnell deutlich werden.
Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass der Süden und der Osten jetzt besonders datenschutz ähm rigide wäre, oder?
Nö, das heißt nur, dass mir das dort noch nicht so aufgefallen ist, was wesentlich auch mit der weniger dort weniger stark verbreiteten Vernetzung von Gesundheitssystemen zu tun hat.
Verstehe, die sind einfach noch nicht so weit. Ähm.
Wie bewerten sie denn jetzt den konkreten.
Ablauf ähm die Datenschutzverordnung war ja im Prinzip des
das umkämpfteste Rechtsprojekt eigentlich der letzten Jahre, wenn man sich nur die Zahl der äh Änderungsanträge anschaut
Ähm es gab ja also eine ungeheure äh Lobby-Aktivität, die ja dann auch zu so,
geführt hat wie Lobbywatch und so, dann eigens noch Software äh entwickelt wurde, um sozusagen diesen ganzen Änderungswald überhaupt noch zu überblicken.
Warum gerade hier und was hat das für eine Auswirkung gehabt auf diesen ganzen Prozess?
Also warum gerade hier, glaube ich, deswegen, weil das halt ähm ein enorm wichtiger Text ist für die gesamte digitale Ökonomie der nächsten zehn bis zwanzig Jahre, denn man muss schon realistischerweise sagen, dass es der Europäischen Union vielleicht alle zehn Jahre gelingt, so einen Wurf zu werfen.
Und das bedeutet, dass der Text, von dem wir da jetzt reden, äh die halt die gesamte IT in den nächsten zehn bis fünfzehn, zwanzig Jahren in Europa,
wenn es um Datenschutz geht, gestaltet und das da ist genügend Geld und genügend Politik und Macht im Spiel, um wichtig zu sein. Das ist, glaube ich, das Warum.
Ähm ähm das Ergebnis ist, um mal mit dem, also um mal mit was Positivem zu beginnen, es ist erstaunlich und ich hätte vor
vor den Snowden Leaks eigentlich gar nicht mehr damit gerechnet
es ist erstaunlich, dass man sich in Europa überhaupt auf irgendetwas einigen konnte. Und es ist ein großes politisches Verdienst der Beteiligten, also insbesondere auch das Parlaments und auch des Berichterstatters im Parlament, der eher Deutscher ist. Jan-Philipp Albrecht, dass das am Ende wirklich zu etwas geworden ist. Also das es einen Text gibt
über den äh man sich einigen konnte. Der Preis äh dafür war, dass man an vielen Stellen halt Kompromisse gefunden hat
und eben auch, dass man an vielen Stellen nur aber immerhin den bisherigen Status Quo fortgeschrieben hat. Also es wird sich vermutlich,
nicht so wahnsinnig viel ändern, ähm auch gerade aus deutscher,
gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel ändern im Vergleich zu dem Startsystem, den wir schon hatten. Also die Grundprinzipien sind sehr ähnlich. Letztlich sind auch die grundrechtlichen Fundamente ja gar nicht
angerührt, weil die ja gar nicht durch die durch die Verordnung veränderbar sind. Das steht ja direkt in der Grundrechte-Karte
ähm und im Vertrag über die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union, also das hat sich gar nicht verändert und auch, also wie gesagt, die Prinzipien, die ursprünglich in der Richtlinie waren, sind in erstaunlich.
Konsistenterweise eigentlich fortgeschrieben. Man wird also vermutlich gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel merken.
Also ist das dein überflüssig? Kann man das jetzt so auslegen, muss ich sagen?
Würde ich auf keinen Fall so sagen wollen. Ja, ich glaube also überhaupt nicht, äh dass es überflüssig wäre, Datenschutz zu regeln äh und auch mit rechtlichen Instrumenten zu regeln. Ich glaube nur, dass sehr viele Probleme, die wir in dem Feld haben.
Ähm weiter bestehen könnten, ja können, nicht könnten.
Weiterbestehen können und ein eminentes Problem eben da, also gibt hunderte eminente Probleme im Datenschutzrecht. Aber ein ganz wichtiges ist ja eben die die das Vollzugsdefizit, ne, dass wir also ein amerikanischer Rechtswissenschaftler,
mal, als er den äh das europäische das erste Mal gelesen hat,
einen Aufsatz geschrieben, der mit dem Aufsatz äh der mit dem ersten Satz beginnt.
Constant, nicht?
Und irgendwie stimmt das ja auch vielleicht, ne? Also die die Vollzugsdefizite, die wir im Datenschutzrecht haben
Zum Beispiel oder auch die Probleme, die wir mit der informierten Einwilligung haben, zum Beispiel
ähm oder die Probleme, die wir haben in der Abwägung zwischen Datenschutz auf der einen Seite und Informationsfreiheit auf der anderen Seite.
All diese Probleme werden nicht einfach weggehen, wenn jetzt die Datenschutzgrundverordnung kommt, denn sehr viel, was da an Regeln vorgesehen ist, ist nicht so anders zu dem, was wir schon haben.
Und genau da wäre doch jetzt eigentlich der Punkt gewesen, wo man ein.
Wo man dem Ziel eines Datenschutzrechts für das einundzwanzigste und wahrscheinlich sogar zweiundzwanzigste Jahrhundert ähm und auf der anderen Seite einer Vereinheitlichung innerhalb der EU.
Hätte näher kommen können. Und da sagen sie das, das ist in der Form in keiner Form. Das ist.
Ja genau, das ist halt jetzt natürlich, ich meine, ich sitze da sehr bequem im akademischen Lehnstuhl, nicht, dann schaue mir das also außerhalb des politischen Prozesses an und, und, und, und sehe dann halt Defizite im geltenden Recht und denke dann, äh darüber nach, wie man das vielleicht in abstrakter ändern könnte.
Mir ist schon ganz klar, dass das also in der politischen Realität anders abläuft, aber man muss trotzdem jetzt eben einfach sagen, dass äh also die ganz großen Dinge, ähm
eigentlich nicht wirklich angegangen wurden. Von Beginn an, schon von der Kommission, nicht wirklich angegangen wurden.
Aber betet die Verordnung jetzt vielleicht, zumindest eine stabile Diskussionsbasis, um jetzt die nächsten Schritte anzugehen. Ich meine, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht dann schon mal äh äh vielleicht gut, dass man.
So eine Fest, also selbst wenn's der Status quo ist, aber er ist halt sozusagen festgeschrieben, was was werden denn so jetzt die nächsten
Bedarf. Also sie meinen ja in dem Text gefühlt ist das Ding jetzt schon siebzig Jahre alt, weil man irgendwie zehn Jahre drüber diskutiert hat und das Internet alles mal sieben nimmt. Ähm was was sind denn so die nächsten
dringenden Fragen, die im Prinzip auch auf EU-Regende Ebene geregelt werden sollten, aber jetzt noch nicht sind.
Also ich würde gar nicht so laut nach Regulierung schreien, jetzt nicht. Das ist ja auch eine Krankheit äh von Juristen, dass sie ständig rufen, äh
dass irgendwas neu reguliert werden muss, ähm aber ich würde ganz gerne danach rufen, dass man die Diskussion,
beendet, nicht? Also die Datenschutzgrundverordnung ist ein schöner Zwischenschritt vielleicht
es ist ein Zwischenschritt, der auch deswegen möglich war, weil eben nationale Öffnungsklausel weiterhin vorhanden sind, deswegen kann auch jeder seine nationale Sonderlocke weiter pflegen
ähm und man muss jetzt gerade anfangen, glaube ich, zwei Dinge zu erledigen, nämlich erstens die Grundsatzdiskussion zu führen, also macht das noch Sinn
hat das Erfolg, führt das zu dem Ergebnis, das wir eigentlich erreichen wollen
und gleichzeitig die evidenten Vollzugsdefizite endlich mal in den Blick zu kriegen. Also arbeiten Datenschutzbehörden, so wie sie sollen, äh ist es wahr, dass Unternehmen äh
sich anpassen an das oder auch Behörden sich anpassen an die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen, weil Datenschutzbehörden äh sie davon erfolgreich überzeugt haben, dass das notwendig wäre und so weiter. Nicht wir haben ja in Europa, glaube ich, wenn man die Datenschutzbehörden vergleicht, zum Beispiel mit.
Oder auch mit äh Medizinaufsichtsbehörden im Bereich des Datenschutzrechts jetzt nicht wahnsinnig schlagkräftige ähm,
Tiger vor uns und ich glaube, dass man in dem Feld sicher auch viel jetzt auf dem auf der derzeitigen Grundlage schon machen kann, also unabhängig von dieser abstrakten Diskussion, die ich vorher gemeint habe, im im Feld auf,
munitionieren von Datenschutzbehörden und aufmunitionieren der Möglichkeiten von Datenschutzbehörden kann man wahrscheinlich schon nach dem jetzt dann geltenden Recht einiges tun.
Wenn man will.
Ja, aber gut, das äh beantwortet nicht so ganz meine Frage nach etwas so äh also was sind sozusagen jetzt was wären jetzt konkrete Themenfelder oder Fragestellungen, die jetzt in dem Sinne noch nicht abgehandelt sind, die jetzt die nächsten Debatten bestimmen sollen.
Okay, dann habe ich die Frage falsch verstanden. Also ein konkretes äh Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel die Einwilligung
Nicht die informierte Einwilligung und die Anforderungen an die informierte Einwilligung. Da steht jetzt einiges in dem Text drin, einiges davon ist auch sehr auslegungsbedürftig. Ähm also zum Beispiel ist mir nicht ganz klar,
was sich jetzt eigentlich der Unionsgesetzgeber unter dem Stichwort der Freiwilligkeit der Einwilligung wirklich konkret vorstellt, nicht denn das ist ja ein riesen Problem, dass wir
in dem Feld immer haben, dass wir von einer freiwilligen Einwilligung ausgehen, obwohl sie faktisch nicht so wahnsinnig freiwillig ist, weil man ein Angebot bekommt, nicht? Also man kann ja nicht ernsthaft mit Facebook oder mit Google oder mit äh YouTube anfangen,
Einwilligungserklärung zu verhandeln. Ja. Ähm also wir haben jetzt einiges an dieser Einwilligung äh durch die Verordnung geregelt, aber ein paar ganz wichtige Dinge äh sind noch überhaupt nicht angegangen, zum Beispiel die Grundsatzfrage, wie transparent muss das sein?
Bedeutet eigentlich wirklich freiwilligkeit? Ist das eine Willenserklärung? Kann man da zum Beispiel wegen Irrtums anfechten ähm und so weiter. Also
gibt's konkret Dinge, über die man äh jetzt auch schon aufgrund des vorhandenen Textes relativ intensiv äh reden und diskutieren kann. Ich ich persönlich halte das für sehr, sehr wichtig, weil die Einwilligung natürlich ein ein sehr.
Also da ist es ganz evident, dass das defizitär ist, nicht ich weiß nicht, wer äh wer ernsthaft alle diese Einwilligungserklärungen lesen soll, die wir ständig alle,
äh äh Vorgesetzt bekommen und alle ständig nicht lesen während das Recht gleichzeitig von der Fiktion ausgeht,
dass das die Grundlage für die Zulässigkeit der Verarbeitung wäre.
Also wir würden gerne wegkommen von diesem äh einmal äh EU-ler anklicken und dann äh ist alles so, wie Facebook das gemacht hat, hinzu so ein bisschen Datenschutz la carte, dass man nicht nur Privatsphäre Einstellungen äh.
So ein bisschen rumkonfigurieren kann, sondern damit auch quasi die rechtliche Bindung äh damit verkoppelt.
Ja und ich würde auch gerne dazu hinkommen, dass man äh, dass es Incentives gibt oder vielleicht auch Anforderungen gibt, äh Einwilligungserklärungen so zu gestalten.
Dass der, der das erklärt, äh in dem Moment versteht, was er tut, ja. Und dazu gehört, dass der Text nicht mehr sechzig Seiten lang und für.
Ausschließlich für Juristen lesbar sein darf. Also Transparenz ist da ein riesen Thema.
Einfachheit des Verstehens durch technische Hilfsmittel wäre ein Thema Voreinstellungen, die besser möglich wären als bisher, während ein Thema, also technische Instrumente mit einem Wort. Alle diese Dinge könnte man,
Also darüber könnte und müsste man, glaube ich, viel mehr nachdenken, als das bisher geschehen ist.
Und die Verordnung sagt ja weiterhin, also jetzt auch in der, in der Regel über die äh Einwilligung im Grunde genommen nur, dass die Einwilligung informiert sein muss äh und dass sie freiwillig sein muss und was das genau bedeutet äh ist Subjekt intepretation, ne.
Schwierig.
Subjekt Twinterpretation, das ist eigentlich das, was wir weghaben wollten und dass wir jetzt für die nächsten Jahre weiter haben werden.
Ja, also erstens ja, aber zweitens, das ist ja an sich ja noch nicht erstaunlich, nicht? Dann wäre es anders, dann gäb's,
gesamten Berufsstand der Juristen nicht. Also das ist ja genau das, wovon Juristen leben. Äh das Problem hier ist, dass es halt außergewöhnlich viele äh außergewöhnlich schwierig zu interpretierende Dinge geben wird.
Ähm sie hat noch äh in dem Text noch äh
bisschen über die künftige Rolle für die Datenschützer ähm die betrieblichen Datenschützer konkret äh gesprochen. Ähm
Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden, was für Auswirkungen sehen sie denn dort?
Das habe ich auch noch nicht so ganz verstanden, aber ich versuche mal zu erklären, wie weit ich's verstanden habe. Also, dass es in Deutschland
anders als in sehr vielen anderen europäischen Staaten, einen Grundsatz gibt, der lautet, dass jedes Unternehmen und jede Behörde einen Datenschutzbeauftragten braucht.
Abgesehen jetzt von absoluten Ausnahmefällen, also Kleinstunternehmen. Und die Aufgabe dieses Datenschutzbeauftragten ist es,
die äh auf die Einhaltung der datenschutzrechtlichen Regelungen im jeweiligen Arbeitskontext hinzuwirken. Verantwortlich
der Chef oder die Chefin, aber der Datenschutzbeauftragte ist unabhängig und hilft. Und in Deutschland können diese Datenschutzbeauftragten entweder interne sein, also das sind dann
Mitarbeiter oder Mitarbeiterinnen oder es können auch Externe sein, das sind dann Dienstleister, da gibt's einen ganzen Markt in Deutschland, da durchaus große und wichtig ist.
Anderen Staaten ist das nicht so, da gibt's das Konzept nicht also da gibt's keine Datenschutzbeauftragten und es gibt erst recht keine externen Datenschutzbeauftragten
Und eine der politischen Diskussionen in diesem Verordnungsgebungsprozess war jetzt, macht dieses Instrument des Daten,
beauftragten Sinn und wenn es Sinn macht, will man dann auch externe Daten,
Beauftragte ermöglichen oder findet man, dass das unbedingt ein interner sein muss. Und das Ergebnis der Diskussion ist jetzt
ähm nachdem also der unterschiedlichste Dinge vorgeschlagen wurden, dass die äh positive Nachricht ist, ähm es gibt eine Regel über den Datenschutzbeauftragten,
Das ist der Artikel fünfunddreißig, in der Verordnung, so wie er jetzt da steht
aber der gilt für die meisten Privatunternehmen nicht mehr. Also das heißt, nach Artikel fünfunddreißig Absatz eins der Verordnung äh sind die meisten privaten Unternehmen,
jene Unternehmen, bei denen nicht die Datenverarbeitung selbst Kernbereich der Tätigkeit ist, nicht mehr verpflichtet eine Datenschutzbeauftragten,
zu bestellen. Das ist natürlich eine schlechte Nachricht für viele äh deutsche Datenschutzbeauftragte, insbesondere die externen Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Weswegen da große Aufregung sein könnte, wenn es nicht, wie so oft, eine nationale Öffnungsklausel gäbe. Wenn es also nicht in dem Artikel fünfunddreißig auch noch die Regel gibt, gäbe oder gibt,
dass äh die Mitgliedsstaaten auch, wenn sie das wollen, weiterhin externe
Datenschutzbeauftragte in all jenen Bereichen, wo europarechtlich die Bestellung nicht erforderlich ist, weiterhin zulassen.
Und das ist jetzt ein Beispiel für das vorhergenannte, da wird sich also wahrscheinlich wie innerdeutsch gesehen gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel ändern, weil wahrscheinlich äh die
nationalen deutschen Datenschutzbeauftragten erfolgreich am Ende dahingehend lobiert haben werden, dass die derzeitige deutsche Regelung auch weiterhin fortbesteht.
Aber könnte anderes rum auch äh bedeuten, dass Irland auch weiterhin sehr äh facebookfreundlich auftreten kann, indem sie äh einfach sagen, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Ähm.
Ja, das müsste man dann schon äh äh interpretieren, ja, weil also eben eine Verpflichtung besteht nach Artikel fünfunddreißig, unter anderem dann, wenn, ich lese das jetzt mal vor, wenn es oder ich versuche, es fliegen zu übersetzen, wenn es also bei der Datenverarbeitung,
von ihrer Natur aus und ihren Zwecken und ihrem Umfang aus,
ähm so erheblich ist, dass diese äh ständige und systematische Beobachtung ähm ähm der der
Datensubjekte, also der Betroffenen in großem Augen Umfang zum Gegenstand haben. Ja, also das heißt, flächendeckendes Beobachten von äh von Betroffenen
erfordert einen Datenschutzbeauftragten. Man wird jetzt relativ lange darüber diskutieren können, ob Facebook unter diese Klausel fällt oder nicht. Ich glaube, ich kenne die Antwort, die Facebook auf die Frage hat schon jetzt. Äh und darüber wird man lange streiten. Aber prinzipiell ist es so, dass viele Unternehmen mal
auch weiterhin keinen Datenschutzbeauftragten brauchen werden, außerhalb Deutschlands.
Ja ich sag mal äh vielen Dank für ähm diesen Blick.
Ich danke Ihnen, hat mir großen Spaß gemacht, bin ein großer Fan Ihres Blogs und Podcasts und alle, alle möglichen Kanäle, über die ich von Ihnen lese und höre und freue mich sehr, dass wir uns mal so unterhalten konnten.
Das hören wir natürlich gerne.
Die Freude ist ganz auf unserer Seite.
Okay, alles, alles.
Dankeschön. Danke, tschüss. Tschüss.
Tschüss. Ja, die Nost, dem ist nicht viel hinzuzufügen, oder?
Nee, dem ist nicht viel hinzuzufügen und ich freue mich, dass wir auch mal ähm einen einen kompetenten Gelehrten in dieser Sendung.
Aber halten wir doch schon auf den Kongress.
Ah ja, scheiße, stimmt, das kann man so nicht.
Aber vielleicht äh finden wir ja noch andere ähm andere Schätze in unserer Hörerschaft, nennt sich das schon äh so gut entwickelt.
Genau, wenn wir unsere Hörer dann plötzlich auf Heise lesen, dann haben sie auch eine Chance. Carsten wir sofort weg.
Schlagen wir zu. Können wir nix. Okay, das war's. Kurze Sache heute im Vergleich, aber ist ja auch mal schön. Letztes Mal war ja schon so lang. Okay, bis tschüss.
Bis tschüss.
Ist, tschüss.
Tschüss, servus. Bis wiedersehen.